mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis je
voudrais d'abord et chacun de comprendre
à remercier tous ceux qui ont contribué
à l'organisation de cette journée de
travail bien sûr eric woerth en charge
du projet il avait le quai des neiges
des remercie infiniment une nouvelle
fois brice hortefeux brigitte kuster
bruno beschizza ça me rappelle des
souvenirs
georges fenech naturellement bernard
reynès claude goasguen
eric ciotti qui a été tellement investi
sur l'ensemble de ces questions
philippe goujon et guillaume larrivé qui
s'affirme je vois près jour comme l'un
de nos jeunes parmi les plus talentueux
merci à tous ceux qui se sont associés à
nous avocats magistrats syndicat de
police je veux que vous compreniez que
pour nous c'était un sujet eric dont
nous avons beaucoup parlé ce qui est en
cause ce qui est notre priorité
nous voulons mettre un terme à la
fatalité d'une autorité de l'état
bafouée systématiquement jour après jour
l'autorité de l'état doit être rétabli
en france tout se passe aujourd'hui
comme si tous en allait comme si la
république s'abandonnait comme si les
français étaient livrés à eux mêmes face
aux différentes menaces il ya de la
manifestation inédite des policiers tu
as bruno il ya quinze jours je veux dire
pour les policiers cadences infernales
non récupération des jours travaillés 1
million 300 demi heures supplémentaires
effectuées par les policiers et qui ne
sont pas payés la république à quel
socialiste en fait travailler les gens
ne payent pas chaque jour 20 policiers
et gendarmes blessés
c'est une augmentation de 46% par
rapport à 2008
il apparaît à tous que le fonctionnement
de l'état est enrayée or nous croyons en
l'autorité de l'état
je ne peux pas accepter les deux poids
deux mesures il n'est pas besoin de
plonger
il ya longtemps dans les faits divers
par moments se demande si ceux qui nous
gouvernent vivent dans le même pays que
nous blocage d'autoroute pas de sanction
campement sauvage à need you now
formidablement parler annie genevard
campement sauvage qui subsistent sur le
territoire de la république sans que
personne ne dise rien à l'exception des
voisins dont la vie est bouleversée
le pire peut être des anarchistes mais
il ya quelques jours en échec une
perquisition internationale dans la plus
totale impunité des policiers viennent
perquisitionner au domicile d'une
personne suspectée de complicité dans le
terrorisme 40 voyous s'interpose
les policiers s'en vont que dit le garde
des sceaux rien que dit le premier
ministre rien que dit le président de la
république rien sans doute on n'avait
pas dû géolocaliser cette personne
à
je refuse comme vous l'autorité du fait
accompli
le chantage ou des ordres ou la menace
de la rue sans autorité il n'y a pas de
république
la république doit soutenir les forces
de l'ordre
c'est son honneur et c'est son devoir et
la république ne peut pas accepter les
territoires interdits et les voyous qui
se croient tout permis je vais employer
une expression forte
l'insécurité aujourd'hui je le dis aux
français est devenue la règle
nous avons des chiffres qui sont
absolument incontestables puisqu'ils
viennent de l'observatoire national
indépendant de la délinquance qui
compare la situation nous avons laissé
et la situation d'aujourd'hui les
cambriolages produits pour cent des vols
plus de 14%
les atteintes à l'intégrité physique +
12 % les violences sexuelles
+31 pose alors je dois étonné mes chers
amis toutes les coupes sont à la hausse
la délinquance explose
mais je veux reconnaître qu'à une
promesse de la garde des sceaux qui a
été honoré la délinquance explose le
nombre de détenus diminue
quinze cent des pires mois sur la même
période
vous m'entendez bien les chiffres ne
peuvent pas être contestés par personne
sur la même période plus de vols plus de
cambriolages plus d'atteintes à
l'intégrité physique des victimes plus
d'agressions sexuelles
15 cents détenus de moins c'est logique
plus de délinquance moins de délinquants
prison nous devons tourner dos cher
claude tu as raison à la culture de la
déresponsabilisation du laxisme et au
fond à la culture du désarmement morale
et pénale
le désarmement pénale n'est que la
conséquence du désarmement moral auquel
nous assistons quel est notre objectif
la république partout et pour tous nous
nous appelons les républicains nous
voulons la république partout et pour
tous une république qui protège et une
république
pardon de le dire qu'ils n'oublient pas
les victimes s'occuper des délinquants
c'est sans doute nécessaire se
préoccuper des victimes
c'est le devoir de la république la
première des propositions que nous
faisons
je voudrais m'en expliquer en deux
secondes
parce qu'elle est très importante à nos
yeux nous voulons recentrer les forces
de l'ordre sur leur mission première
je veux que vous compreniez ça parce que
c'est très très important quand
l'alternance viendra naturellement les
caisses de l'état étant vide
la stratégie d'économie pour retrouver
de la compétitivité étant prioritaire on
ne pourra pas dépenser un argent qu'on
n'a pas il est donc absolument central
de prendre un moment pour réfléchir à ce
que son ce que devraient être les
missions première et fondamentale de la
police
et de la gendarmerie nos policiers et
nos gendarmes perdre leur temps un temps
précieux à effectuer des tâches que
d'autres pourraient faire et pendant
qu'ils effectuent ces tâches accessoires
ils ne peuvent pas se consacrer aux
tâches essentielles qui sont les leurs
la police et la gendarmerie doivent
assurer l'ordre public pour protéger les
français de rassurer la sécurité la
police et la gendarmerie doivent agir en
termes de renseignements pour garantir
la sécurité des français et la police et
la gendarmerie doivent faire un travail
d'investigation pour retrouver les
coupables de crimes et délits rendu
public investigations appelé sable
police judiciaire ce que vous voulez
ordre public investigations
renseignements et nous ne voulons pas
que les professionnels de l'ordre
républicain que sont les policiers et
les gendarmes sortent de ce triptyque
ordre public
renseignements investigations pour
assurer la sécurité des français
cela ne veut en aucun cas dire que
l'état doit se désengager de sa mission
régalienne sur la sécurité c'est tout le
contraire
un policier armé un gendarme armé formé
à bien autre chose à faire que de
recevoir les procurations les veille
d'élection de s'assurer des passeports
aux documents administratifs
c'est du temps perdu pour des
professionnels qui doivent être des
professionnels de la sécurité qui
doivent et puis au service de la
sécurité et avec ce recentrage de nos
forces de sécurité sur les missions
fondamentales est essentielle nous
allons trouver des marges de manoeuvre
considérable à coût constant pour
assurer la protection des français
cela veut donc dire développer le rôle
et les responsabilités
l'it et des partenaires de la police et
de la gendarmerie
qui sont ils on détecte pas du tout
c'est la vérité que nous devons aux
français nous préparons l'alternance
comment allons-nous faire avec les
multiples contraintes chère michèle
alliot marie qui sont les nôtres et que
tu connais contrainte budgétaire
contrainte politique contrainte
économique et en même temps si l'état
n'assure pas la sécurité
à quoi sert l'état s'agissant des
créations d'emplois on peut
naturellement évoqué le contexte
international l'économie d'entreprise
sur la sécurité
y'a rien à évoquer c'est la
responsabilité des hommes et les femmes
politiques du gouvernement du premier
ministre et du président public y a pas
le choix il faut réussir le premier nos
partenaires ce sont les polices
municipales sert bernard reynès je
souhaite que l'on étende les compétences
administratives et judiciaires des
policiers municipaux
il faut leur donner accès aux fichiers
de police il est absolument
incompréhensible que les policiers
municipaux n'est pas accès au fichier
des personnes recherchées
il faut étendre leurs compétences
judiciaires sous le contrôle
naturellement michel du procureur pour
leur permettre des vérifications et des
contrôles d'identité les policiers
municipaux ne sont pas des
fonctionnaires territoriaux comme les
autres j'ai précités aux obsèques
d'aurélie fouquet cette jeune policière
assassiné par des délinquants sans
scrupules et à cinq ans je sais ce qui
s'est passé pour clarisse à
jean-philippe cette jeune policière
municipale tuée aussi est ce que vous
croyez que les voyous distingue dans les
uniformes
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite que les policiers municipaux
puissent porter les armes non seulement
pour se défendre eux-mêmes mais aussi
pour défendre nos concitoyens et qu'en
conséquence les polices municipales dans
les communes de plus de 10 mille
habitants soir mais de droit sauf à ce
que le conseil municipal décide
qui ne serait pas le cas en quelque
sorte on inverse la charge de la preuve
la sécurité c'est aussi un certain
nombre d'acteurs privés des gardes
statiques inutiles qui utilise un nombre
d'effectifs colossal qui pourrait
parfaitement être fait par des sociétés
privées assermentés encore une fois ce
contrôle du du procureur je maintiens
que les forces de l'ordre n'ont pas
assuré le transfèrement des détenus
il existe des villes de province où
lorsqu'un des deux doit amener devant
son juge
la totalité de la ville n'a plus de
policiers ou de gendarmes disponibles
je rappelle que nous sommes à l'époque
de la visioconférence et je préférerais
que ce soit les magistrats qui se
déplace en prison pour interroger les
détenus
plutôt que ce soit les forces de l'ordre
qui doit déménager les détenus pour les
amener aux magistrats je ne pense pas
que la dignité de la justice y perdrait
emplois que ce soir
les police régionale des transports que
nous mettrons en oeuvre je sais que
christian estrosi cher georges en a
parlé ce matin et c'est également
l'option choisie par valérie pécresse
je vous demande de réfléchir à cela
lorsque j'achète un ticket à la sncf où
lorsqu'on prend un billet à l'air atp ou
lorsqu'on prend un billet sur une
compagnie aérienne qui est responsable
de votre sécurité
c'est l'opérateur à qui l'état a confié
l'exercice de service public et bien la
sécurité dans les trains la sécurité
dans les métros la sécurité dans les ter
doit être la responsabilité de la police
des transports
animé par le concessionnaire qui en vous
vendant son billet vous garantit pas
simplement la sécurité du train ou
l'avion ou du métro vous allez utiliser
mais simplement que vous ne feriez pas
une mauvaise rencontre
parce qu'on a vendu un billet ou qu'on a
laissé passer un fraudeur ou un voyou au
départ de la même façon que dans les
stades de football la sécurité elle est
la responsabilité d'abord du club
organisateur
là encore si on demande à la police à la
gendarmerie de tout faire alors ils ne
font plus rien et de surcroît on ne
verra plus la différence entre l'action
de forces de l'ordre national et
l'action des différents opérateurs
je souhaite que la police des transports
voit ses pouvoirs et ses compétences
élargies les gens admirables qui font la
sécurité sncf par exemple doivent
pouvoir fouiller doivent pouvoir
contrôler doit pouvoir consulter des
fichiers doit pouvoir vérifier des
identités 20 un mot parce qu'on a parlé
sur les autoroutes mais là encore il ya
des concessionnaires d'autoroutes l'état
en quelque sorte abandonne une société
privée l'exploitation économique de
l'autoroute
cette société concessionnaire et
quand responsabilité de la sécurité qui
est la vôtre qui est pas un trou au
milieu de l'autoroute que la glissière
de sécurité tiennent que les panneaux
puisse être clairement lui ai signalé
l'accident
et bien pour les excès de vitesse qui du
temps de jean ce gouvernement décide
d'en rater surtout il trouve le moyen de
voir la délinquance et la mortalité
routière augmenté pour la première fois
depuis plus de dix ans c'est vraiment
pas la plus difficile à faire baisser
je le sais à la demande de jacques
chirac j'avais commencé cette action eh
bien je considère que c'est aux sociétés
concessionnaires des autoroutes de
vérifier qu'ils aient pas de dépassement
de vitesse de contrôler les déplacements
de vitesse et de verbaliser et de
transmettre naturellement aux autorités
judiciaires
lorsqu'il ya des problèmes de retrait de
permis ce n'est pas à des policiers ou
des gendarmes de passer leur temps les
policiers les gendarmes chichon sur
l'autoroute c'est pour poursuivre un
criminel c'est pour poursuivre un
délinquant c'est pour lutter contre le
trafic de drogue c'est pour intervenir
dans ce que sont les missions
régaliennes de la police et de la
gendarmerie et non pas pour faire le
contrôle des excès de vitesse sur une
section d'autoroute qui a été considéré
une entreprise si l'entreprise est
suffisamment respectable pour exploiter
l'autoroute
elle doit garantir la sécurité de ceux
qui paient le bh pour emprunter cet
automne
et ce sont des milliers des dizaines de
milliers d'heures de fonctionnaire de
police ou d'un militaire de la
gendarmerie que nous récupérons au
service de notre action centrale qui est
rétablissement de l'autorité dans la
république et la garantie de la sécurité
de nos concitoyens
j'ajoute qu'il faut sans doute et ça
sera un sujet très difficile que nous
revoyons l'organisation de la police de
la gendarmerie autour de ce que
j'appelle les bassins de délinquance car
les voyous ignore parfaitement les
frontières administratives
l'élu de l'oise qui eric woerth s'est
parfaitement que la délinquance dans
l'oise c'est pas une délinquance de
résidence
c'est une délinquance de passage loi
c'est en situées entre la capitale et la
province et territoire plus éloignée de
la capitale et peu importe pour eux si
la police de l'oise pour être efficace
ou la gendarmerie
c'est dans une réflexion de bassins de
délinquance qui regroupera la totalité
de ce bassin aux fonctions d'expression
que nous aurons donné les statistiques
de manière à être beaucoup plus
performant que nous le sommes ça voudra
dire cher philippe goujon police
d'agglomération et çà voudra bien dire
qu'il faudra un jour poser la question
de la police à paris et de la police
municipale à paris paris ne peut pas
être la seule cité où il n'y a pas de
police municipale et où tout repose
exclusivement sur la police d'état je
souhaite également que les mères ce vous
qui sont en première ligne sur patrick
ollier se voit confier d'autres pros
pouvoir nous avions créé bernard s'en
souvient compagnon de loi sur la
prévention de délinquance
le rappel à l'ordre vous savez que le
maire peut prononcer un rappel à l'ordre
à l'époque cher eric c'était comme une
révolution j'apparaissais comme un
révolutionnaire de permettre au premier
magistrat de la commune de faire un
rappel alan ça c'était 2007
je parle pour 2017 nous devons changer
notre manière de voir les choses est de
construire
je souhaite que ce rappel à l'ordre du
maire soit transformé en pouvoir
d'injonction du maire sur le fauteur de
trouble avec possibilité d'interdire à
ce fauteur de trouble de paraître
temporairement dans certains lieux de la
commune notamment aux abords des
collèges et des lycées
là aussi mes chers amis il faut
réfléchir à tout cela
c'est un traction ces délits sont à la
fois extrêmement traumatisant et sur
l'échelle des délits ne sont pas est-ce
que vous comprenez de la même grille je
ne banalise pas mais c'est pas la même
gravité un viol et un fauteur de
troubles mais la tranquillité publique
commence par là eh bien nous souhaitons
que les mères est un pouvoir d'interdire
un fauteur de troubles d'être devant un
collège racketteurs d'être devant un
lycée d'interdire en cas de bagarre dans
un quartier dette dans tel ou tel
immeuble ou devant l endroit et c'est
pas la peine de remonter au commissaire
de police au préfet au procureur de la
république
c'est un pouvoir qui doit appartenir au
maire
je souhaite également que dans les
quartiers les trafiquants de drogue voit
la peine complémentaire automatique
d'interdiction de séjour là où elle a
commis son méfait que cette peine soit
automatique à sa sortie de prison
cole trafic de drogue qui a rendu
impossible la vie dans un quartier fass
sa peine de prison
je souhaite une peine d'interdiction de
retour dans son quartier une fois la
peine de prison effectuée pour qu'ils ne
viennent pas en jouer les caïds en
disant voilà j'ai fait ma peine de
prison
un peu en quelque sorte comme une
décoration je souhaite également pour la
centaine esquissons sens qu'ils sont 150
on en parlera
mais deux quartiers abandonnés de la
république je souhaite que soient créées
et ouvert des postes permanents que
j'appelle de vigie policière uniquement
la nuit car c'est pas la peine de nous
faire le coup de la police de sécurité
avec des policiers qui défilent ou qui
font des patrouilles entre 8h du matin
et midi qui disent bonjour à la crémière
et qu'ils vont faire un tour au marché
parce qu'à cette heure-là les clients de
la police et de la gendarmerie
ils sont pas réveillés
donc les heures de fonctionnaires
commerce et or la chaire bruno tu le
sait mieux que personne
notamment dans son département la seine
saint denis c'est sympathique ça rassure
mais ça ne sert à rien et je parle sous
contrôle dérivant à qui je dis mon
amitié
lui qui a tellement bien travaillé que
nous étions ensemble
je souhaite que dans ces quartiers des
vigies policière soit ouverte à partir
de 20 heures et jusqu'à 6 heures du
matin et que les malheureux habitants de
ces quartiers qui se sentent abandonnés
de tous et toutes puissent se dire je
pourrais appeler la vigie de nuit et
qu'on ne vienne pas me dire que ça va
nous prendre beaucoup d'effectifs et qui
va falloir tenir ces endroits parce que
moi qui a engagé les forces de les crs
dans les quartiers je ne veux plus d'une
situation où pendant trois semaines vous
avez des tas de crs qui propose et qui
font des contrôles d'identité crs qui
met de montauban pour garder la
courneuve
merci pour trouver des renseignements
et puis une fois que la compagnie repart
il ya plus personne et le quartie se
sent encore plus abandonné avec ce
système de vigie tous les soirs dans la
centaine de quartiers nous considérons
que la république a abandonné ses droits
et ses responsabilités il y aura une
vigie et le mot vigie un sens c'est un
commissaire de police avec les papiers
administratifs avec la main courante
c'est une vigie qui est là pour dire la
république revient ici ça plaît pas aux
délinquants c'est eux qui céderont et
c'est pas la république du sénat
cher ami tu as bien parler des
procédures d'occupation illicite des
terrains
je voudrais proposer une seule mesure
supprimer tous les recours suspensif à
l'exécution de la mesure d'expulsion
je connais des tas de victimes qui n'ont
pas les moyens de se payer un avocat
je ne connais pas un campement illégal
qui n'a pas une batterie d'avocats pour
utiliser tous les recours pour obtenir
la suspension des décisions c'est un
scandale
enfin je souhaite que même si c'est un
sujet sensible que la question de notre
législation sur la légitime défense des
forces de l'ordre évolué quand les
policiers les gendarmes sont face à un
danger imminent
je pense qu'il faut renverser la charge
de la preuve préciser les règles
d'engagement de l'armée feu je souhaite
que nos policiers et nos gendarmes
bénéficient d'une présomption de
légitime défense
et quand même
quand un individu a une arme à feu et
qu'il se trouve devant un policier un
gendarme et qu'il refuse de laisser
tomber son arme à feu il faut attendre
t-il tir pour que les policiers les
gendarmes puissent se défendre dans quel
pays vivons nous ce n'est pas la
république que nous voulons nous voulons
une république qui protège les victimes
et qu'il n'explose pas des représentants
des forces de l'anp et qu'on ne vienne
pas me faire le procès de quoi que ce
soit en la matière il s'agit pas de
permettre n'importe quoi j'ai toujours
dit que les forces de l'ordre
utilisaient la force républicaine mais
on ne peut pas considérer parce qu'on
est policier un gendarme l'état en
quelque sorte acheter le droit de voir
mourir des jeunes femmes ou des jeunes
hommes parce que on n'aurait pas décidé
la république n'aurait pas décidé
d'assurer leur protection
un mot sur ce que georges et claude ou
d'évoquer parfaitement bien qui est
l'autorité de la loi
la peine et son exécution
au fond tout converge dans la politique
pénale actuelle pour altérer comment
dit-on pour dévitalisées pour annihiler
le sens de la peine et de la sanction
or la certitude de la sanction participe
de quoi bon un équilibre social et
sociétal
donc je veux combattre cette idée folle
que la prison serait l'école du crime
ce n'est pas la prison qui crée la
récidive c'est la récidive qui crée la
prison il faut arrêter avec cela
la fameuse fable du tout carcéral n'a
jamais existé que dans l'esprit des
idéologues du désarmement pénal ni
chiffres l'encore mes chers amis n'y a
pas besoin de faire polémique
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes ce sont
des chiffres du conseil de l'europe au
1er septembre 2013
il y avait en france 57 1435 places de
prison incontestable
la même année il y en avait 77 1243 en
allemagne vont me dire oui mais
l'allemagne c'est plus propre et la
france parfait et bien la v60 7895 en
espagne qui a un tiers de population au
moins que la france et 97 1260 au
royaume uni qui a grosso modo la même
population que la france donc l'idée du
tout carcéral en france est un mensonge
ça n'existe nulle part nous avions
pendant les cinq ans du quinquennat elle
s'en souvient construit 10 % de places
de prison plus 7000
la priorité c'est de faire vingt mille
places de prison pour atteindre les 90
mille places parce que c'est quand même
insensé d'équilibrer le nombre ou de
définir le nombre de détenus au nombre
de places c'est le nombre de places qui
doit être défini par rapport au nombre
de détenus
ou alors c'est qu'une république qui
marchent totalement sur la tête
je ne ne cautionnerait pas un discours
trop systématique puissant faire passer
les magistrats pour laxiste ce que je
pense c'est qu'il ya un problème sur le
moment pénitentiaire l'exécution des
décisions de justice pénale est la
grande oubliée de la chaîne pénale et
donc guillaume larrivé je signe des deux
mains
la peine doit on doit arrêter la
déconstruction de la peine
l'inexécution de la peine 100 mille
tonnes par an et je reconnais bien
volontiers que ce n'est pas un sujet
cher eric qui a commencé avec monsieur
hollande
j'en prends ma part de responsabilité
aussi ma phase qui a commencé avec
monsieur hollande c'est une aggravation
phénoménal de la situation une peine
prononcée doit être une peine exécutée
et par conséquent toute peine supérieure
à 6 mois sera intégralement exécuté
voilà la politique pénale que nous
proposons
les peines plancher claude a eu raison
de faire la différence entre les
récidivistes et les réitérant m'enfin
dans mon esprit la récidive
c'est la récidive du crime ou du délit
peu importe le crime ou le délit
si on est dans ce jésuite is ben là
c'est qu'on ne comprend rien à la
situation que vivent les français
non mais pas toi mais je me suis permis
ça parce que j'ai beaucoup d'affection
pour lui mais sinon je ne serais pas
permis
comprenez moi pour tout français qui
réfléchit le récidiviste celle
récidiviste dans le délit est dans le
crime alors bien m'expliquer et
maintenant réitérant parce que le
premier a fait un violent depuis la
simple un vol à main armée ah oui
d'accord rien alors là c'est pas un
récidiviste il commence sa carrière donc
non non non pour nous c'est pas comme ça
la carrière
elle commence par le délit et par le
crime peu importe
comprenez moi bien je ne met pas sur le
même plan comme trompait renard et veut
nommer cette espèce de jésuitisme mal
digéré sur le vocabulaire au fond masque
quoi masquer l'immobilisme la lâcheté et
la volonté de ne pas agir est de ne pas
prendre à bras le corps les problèmes
des français en matière de sécurité
nous devons être courageux je dis
d'autant plus que pour moi je souhaite
qu'il n'y ait pas d'examen de libération
conditionnelle avant l'exécution d'au
moins les deux tiers de la peine ils
n'ont pas de la moitié de la peine je
souhaite que les mécanismes de révision
automatique du sursis soit revu
complètement et je me demande encore
pourquoi monsieur hollande a voulu la
suppression des peines planchers alors
on parle beaucoup de la convention
climat très intéressant et du principe
de précaution très intéressant
le principe de précaution pour tous mais
les mêmes qui défendent le principe de
précaution pour protéger l'écologiste
j'accepte parfaitement n'applique pas le
principe de précaution sur les
si davis lorsqu'il s'agit de faire les
peines plancher parce que les plaines
plancher ce n'était rien d'autre qu'un
principe de précaution appliqué aux
victimes
monsieur ça fait quatorze fois que vous
venez devant le tribunal correctionnel
vous allez donc ré deux punis pour la
quatorzième le 14e délit que vous avez
connu comme y est aussi pour toute votre
carrière précédente qui vient éclairer
la force du 14e délit que vous venez de
connaître
par ailleurs je souhaite qu'on prévoit
l'interdiction du territoire national
pour toute personne de nationalité
étrangère condamnés pour crime ou pour
délit supérieure à 5 ans quand on a une
carrière pareil on n'a plus rien à faire
sur le territoire de la république
française
la justice des mineurs en m'excusant
mais ça prouve qu'on travaille ensemble
et qu'on est d'accord quand même un sens
il vaut mieux que je dise la même chose
que mes amis serait un peu curieux
n'existe contraire mais j'aurais bien à
ma manière
d'abord cette idée juge pour enfants
vous avez un gaillard d'un mètre 90 de
17 ans qui est déjà venu 18 fois et oui
où tu vas je vais voir le juge pour
enfants ah bon tu es un petit frère et à
quelqu'un va mourir nos m pardon mais la
sémantique un sens ça ne veut absolument
plus rien dire la vie a évolué et nous
tous dans nos familles nous le savons on
ne parle pas nos enfants comme on
parlait comme nos grands parents ou nos
parents nous parlait on peut le
regretter mais c'est ainsi et un jeune
de 14 ans 15 ans aujourd'hui n'a rien à
voir avec ces jeunes
quatorze ou quinze avaient compris à mon
époque
moi je me souviens très bien j'allais au
cinéma
peut-être une ou deux fois dans l'année
et d'ailleurs c'était pas grave puisque
les films rester à l affiche trois ans
c'est le moyen-age d'accord je sais je
sais je suis très très vieux ouais moi
j'ai l'impression d'avoir 18 ans
toujours je me souviens très bien que
j'avais été emmenée voir mon premier
film pour ma tante pardon je sais pas
pourquoi je vous parle de ça enfin bon
ça me fait plaisir au kilo panorama
place clichy
c'était ben-hur charlton heston c'est
resté quand je dis trois ans et
peut-être même resté quatre ans le monde
a changé
on ne peut pas garder la même
dénomination et la même organisation
ça n'a pas de sens je crois que c'est
une idée très forte très nouvelle
effectivement georges que celle de la
césure entre un tribunal de la famille
qui regrouperait les trois compétences
actuelles du juge des affaires
familiales divorce droit de visite et
d'hébergement pension alimentaire
les compétences actuelles de qui pas du
juge civil
je pense à l'adoption je pense à
l'identité d'enfants je pense jaliya la
reconnaissance de paternité et le juge
des enfants dans sa pratique
je sais pas pourquoi je te cite comme ça
parce que tu as en face de moi j'aurais
pu citer sébastien et celle du juge des
enfants dans sa partie éducative et
prestations sociales
donc vous voyez qu'on aurait un tribunal
de la famille qui traiterait tous les
problèmes des mineurs et à côté un
tribunal pénal pour mineurs qui jugerait
les crimes et délits commis par les
mineurs et qui permettrait quelque chose
d'extraordinairement important qui
aujourd'hui interdit
c'est la comparution immédiate
applicable aux mineurs de plus de 16 ans
je rappelle qu'en 2013 parmi les deux
cent trente-quatre mille mineurs
impliqués dans des affaires pénales la
moitié avait 16 ou 17 ans donc il y
avait vraiment une
une césure entre la partie éducative et
la partie sanction pénale j'ajoute que
je souhaite qu'il n'y ait plus un seul
mineurs emprisonnés dans une prison avec
des adultes
ils compris naturellement lorsqu'il ya
un quartier pour mineurs
je ne crois pas à la pertinence du même
lieu pour l'emprisonnement des mineurs
et des majeurs et nous avons créé je
veux dire quand cinq ans nous avons créé
50 et un centre éducatif fermé pour
mineurs et six établissements
pénitentiaires pour mineurs
monsieur hollande avait promis le
doublement une promesse de plus qui
naturellement n'a pas été tenue donc non
seulement il faut monter à 80 mille
places de prison mais il faut prévoir
des établissements spécifiques pour les
mineurs totalement déconnectée des
majeures je pense que c'est absolument
essentiel deux derniers mots nous
pensons et c'est grave que toutes les
leçons n'ont pas été tirées des
attentats terroristes et de la gravité
de la menace terroriste
à l'époque eric ciotti avait fait des
propositions
je voudrais y revenir le nombre de
français engagés dans une filière
jihadiste a été triplé en une amie
triplé si nous ne réagissons pas c'est
que nous continuons à sous-estimer une
menace essentielle alors sur les
djihadistes
s'ils sont français et qu'ils reviennent
du jihad
ils doivent être immédiatement incarcéré
le jihad
c'est l'apprentissage de la lutte pour
la destruction de la république
française vous avez fait jihad case
prison immédiatement et s'ils sont
étrangers binationaux il ne met pas les
pieds sur le territoire
j'ajoute que je ne comprends pas
pourquoi le gouvernement refuse toujours
avec un entêtement coupable a considéré
que la consultation d'un site internet
fondamentaliste est un délit chers amis
la consultation d'un site pédophile
c'est de la pédophilie
la consultation d'un site
fondamentalistes et terroristes c'est du
terrorisme et donc ça doit être
sanctionné pour ce que c'est j'ajoute
que nous devons créer les conditions
d'un système efficace de renseignements
en milieu carcéral
il faut mettre en place une communauté
du renseignement qui doit bénéficier de
nouveaux moyens technologiques
on ne peut pas rester désarmés face à ce
que tout le monde c'est la
radicalisation d'un certain nombre de
nos prisons
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons une dernière proposition qui est
celle de créer un grand ministère de la
sécurité qui se verrait rattacher les
douanes ont plus de la police et de la
gendarmerie
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique j'ai la
chance de diriger les douanes et diriger
la police et la gendarmerie
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique mis à part
la collecte de la tva
quelle est la différence de travail
entre un douanier et un policier de
l'air et des frontières
et je ne vois pas au nom de quelle
logique la douane obéirait ministre et
la police de l'air et des frontières
un autre ministre c'est une déperdition
considérable au moment où il ya un tel
problème de contrôle est garantie de nos
frontières
il me semble que la réintroduction
l'introduction de la douane pour emploi
met au service du ministère de
l'intérieur est essentielle je voudrais
vous dire que je demande la même chose
pour le personnel pénitentiaire et je
vais m'en expliquer le personnel
pénitentiaire sont des gens font un
travail extraordinairement utile
extraordinairement difficile mais quel
est ce travail s'agit pas simplement
d'appliquer une décision de justice
il s'agit d'assurer la sécurité des
français
en gardant dans un univers fermé des
délinquants qui présentent un danger
pour la société
c'est donc ni plus ni moins qu'une
mission de sauvegarde de la sécurité des
français
j'ajoute avec ce que j'ai dit sur le
renseignement que si les personnels
pénitentiaires travaillent main dans la
main avec la police et la gendarmerie
ira pas besoin d'inventer une nouvelle
usine à gaz pour savoir qui donne son
enseignement
comment on organise le renseignement et
comment doit être tenu leur enseignement
et enfin il y aura plus la sempiternelle
bagarre pour savoir entre la
pénitentiaire où la police et la
gendarmerie qui fait le transfèrement
des détenus
écoutez quand il le procès colonna que
tous les jours il a fallu amener le sur
colonna avec un hélicoptère au dessus de
sa tête
deux fourgons de police devant trois
fourgons de police derrière et un palais
de justice mais en situation de camp
retranché
sans doute n'était ce pas le l'exemple
plus choquant mais vous voyez les
effectifs que ça prend pendant ce temps
la mission de recherche des délinquants
la mission protection des français
ou est ce qu'elle en est et qu'est-ce
qui se passe donc vous voyez que
l'organisation de ce grand ministère me
semble-t-il est absolument essentiel
dans le même temps et je remercie
eric woerth de sa compréhension
nous avons décidé d'attendre
c'est sur sa bonne mine que vous
l'applaudissait nous avons décidé que
compte tenu de la gravité de la menace
terroriste et de la situation
d'insécurité structurelles gravissime
quel endroit la france les mesures de
diminution dans la fonction publique ne
s'appliquerait pas à la police aux
services de renseignement et à la
gendarmerie parce que la situation est
trop grave et c'est une exception une
seule qui devrait être engagée il me
semble que nous devions j'ajoute
charbonneau que les heures
supplémentaires et la définition d'un
nouveau système de corps et carrières
pardon pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
mais avec la réforme des retraites et
les policiers qui vont rester entre 5 et
10 sont plus au travail
si on ne change pas l'organisation de la
gestion des carrières on paralyse
complètement
les corps et le choix que nous faisons
c'est naturellement le choix de la
confiance au fond ce pardon d'avoir été
sans doute trop trop long mais je
voulais que vous compreniez que pour
nous les républicains
chez brigitte kuster c'est quelque chose
de central que le rétablissement de
l'autorité de l'état
c'est vraiment la priorité des priorités
et nous avons bien conscience
tout ce que sur la question de la
sécurité il ne peut pas y avoir de faux
semblants on ne peut pas repousser les
responsabilités d'un échec ou d'un
succès sur qui que ce soit d'autre
ça sera notre responsabilité et enfin
comme nous avons pris l'habitude des
questions vous être soumise ces bougies
je crois qu'il va vous en donner lecture
et chaque adhérent de notre mouvement
pourra s'exprimer avec un petit
changement à compter de ce soir 18h et
jusqu'à vendredi 18h parce qu'on m'a dit
c'est trop court c'est bon et vous voyez
que je démonte par là même une capacité
assez exceptionnelle d' écoute
et d'intégration merci à tous